okay so what happens if there is an
outbreak for a given team if a position
group is decimated by covet 19 positives
what powers will the commissioner have
to step in and provide relief
to postpone to cancel to suspend play
sean payton acknowledged earlier this
week he believes games will be suspended
and he specifically tied it to position
groups being wiped out on a given team
peter flagged this issue in football
morning in america earlier this week
peter let's talk about this
the logistics the standards the fairness
or lack thereof and we're already being
conditioned to accept the fact that
competitive balance goes out the window
this year we're gonna have to tolerate
things like some teams having fans
some teams not having fans but the idea
that there will be the possibility
of pulling the plug on a given game
i really do think it's critical that
there be a clear standard that everyone
feels good about and understands because
you can have some teams thinking wait a
minute we should have gotten a
dispensation for today we didn't another
team did let's kind of
talk through
how that all would happen if the
commissioner does have this power to on
a per game basis say this team isn't
ready to go today
yeah i think this is something that is
in very preliminary uh discussion
um one of the things that i had heard is
that uh roger goodell was asking those
close to him
around the nfl uh certainly members of
the competition committee some owners
uh maybe all owners you know give me
your ideas
you know in case there's an outbreak on
a team what do we do
and that is where the idea of mike
remember back in april or may when we
talked about the portability of the
schedule and the ability of the the nfl
to basically move the schedule perhaps
complete weeks move the schedule
you know into later in the year
and that is where i think he's going to
have to have
the flexibility and the wherewithal if
he chooses to
if he feels that there's a real
competitive imbalance and i use the uh
uh example of
if on thursday a team's entire offensive
line or four of the five offensive
linemen uh test positive
you know he has to have the ability at
least i believe to say okay we're not
going to allow this team to take the
field this week and we're going to move
that game that they're playing
into a new week 18
which would be played you know on sunday
january 10
the week after the regular season ends
which was supposed to be the big wild
card weekend you delay the wild card
weekend one week
and then you play whatever games you
might need to play
in that other window now
that leads to this question well what if
this outbreak is outbreak is 15 people
and it's gonna be two or three weeks
well
i've also heard that it's possible
possible
that a consideration could be made that
this would be
a year where every team doesn't play 16
games
and everyone is going to be totally up
in arms with that i get it
but
i remember writing this after talking to
nfl people in may
and i wrote that after talking to enough
of them
people have to be ready for what i
called a holy unfair season
because i believe this has the potential
to be a wholly unfair season
what are you seeing in baseball right
now the philadelphia phillies are going
a week without playing baseball games
they're not making up every one of those
games instead of playing 60 they might
play 57 or whatever
and so my whole point is
that's not the biggest disaster in the
world okay
so if team x plays 14 games and team y
and team z
play 15 or however it works out and
everybody else plays 16 you know get
over it that's the way life goes this
year
well and i agree with that that it may
be a necessity i think it's one of the
reasons why we've seen the commissioner
pivot in recent days from saying that
the commitment is to play a full season
to playing a complete season because
complete means
the season is complete here is the super
bowl trophy it means here's the trophy
1982 was a complete season they only
played nine regular season games because
of the strike and this is what it feel
it's got that 1982 feel it's got the 87
feel even though the replacements won't
take over the league for three weeks
these replacement players are going to
be constantly bubbling into rosters and
who knows how good any of these guys are
when they're lined up next to nfl
caliber talent and it's going to feel
probably a little bit like 1943 when the
steelers and the eagles had to combine
forces due to world war ii and the
cleveland rams suspended play for a full
year because they didn't have enough
guys and guys were working 40 hours a
week in in factories with uh you know
assignments to help the war effort while
they were also playing football so it's
going to be a strange year if the
alternative is don't play at all i say
let's give it a try and see what happens
but i really do feel like that let's see
what happens vibe is is a real thing the
nfl's embraced it and uh you know peter
i you mentioned the way the schedule is
set up and i want to underscore this
i believe they are committed to going
forward with week one and because they
aren't playing pre-season games and
because they are in this mini bubble
team by team it creates a greater
likelihood that we will see week one but
then week two week three week four who
knows every game week two
involves teams that have their buys the
same week so to your point if we're just
going to postpone some of them they very
easily get nestled into the bye weeks
that those teams would have otherwise
had or you could just pull the plug on
the whole week and say we'll see you
week three or week four or week five
because weeks three and four no
divisional games they could be scrapped
or they could be tacked on to the end of
the season so there's a lot of
flexibility built into the schedule i
firmly believe we're going forward with
week one it's going to be let's go with
week one and then we'll take a step back
and wait and see how many positives pop
up
i think the one point to keep in mind as
you think about the schedule
is that you know
there have been people in the scheduling
department not just howard cats who've
worked on this schedule and done this
for more than 10 years and their job
essentially
is to think of every single
possible ramification
so i will guarantee you
in a league right now where roger
goodell says hope is not a strategy
there is a lot of work being done behind
the scenes to make sure that they are
surprised by nothing
well and uh the thing is this year we're
going to be surprised by everything and
there will be plans that are made ahead
of time plans that you come up on come
up with on the fly and the commissioner
i think is going to be far busier this
year than he is in any other football
season usually the highest profile
person from the league office peter once
the season starts is the head of
officiating i think this year the
commissioner is going to be a lot more
involved he's going to have to be
involved there's going to be some tough
decisions to make if these outbreaks
happen and you're right we may have some
teams with 15 14 13 games some with 16
who knows who knows what you know we
were talking about this earlier in the
week the over under
average game per team
i'd put it at nine and a half right now
i really like because i i mean because
that's right at the spot where i'm not
quite sure how many games we're gonna
have when it's all said and done um and
maybe 10 and a half maybe nine and a
half would make me inclined to bet the
over always look for that number that
makes me think i'm not really sure maybe
10 and a half i don't know peter what's
your sense of of what that magic number
is between uh how many games we will and
won't see
i think you're going to see at least 14
games per team
uh i i look you know the nfl has come
too far
and done too many things
to try to make this season happen
i will be extremely surprised if there
are these
pockets of outbreaks that force the nfl
to cancel let's say
seven weeks per team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports